the Texas Republican senator Ted Cruz
plans to meet with President Trump
during his visit to Texas later today
the senator was here at the convention
center yesterday visiting the thousands
of people seeking shelter he joins us
now on the phone
senator Cruz good morning morning or
it's good to be with you I know you're
gonna be visiting with President Trump
in Corpus Christi what do you want him
to know what does your state need well
the state is hurting right now
we're still in an active crisis
situation in Houston as you know the
rain is coming down it rained all night
this is this is now the fourth day in a
row of pounding rain and and the
flooding is unlike anything we've ever
seen before this is a 500-year flood I
grew up in Houston we've seen a lot of
hurricanes in Houston what we haven't
seen is a hurricane that just parks over
the city and and dumps four to five feet
of rain on the city and the flooding
there's still a lot of people who are in
dangerous situations the first
responders are are truly demonstrating
heroism that the firefighters and police
officers and EMT a Coast Guardsman a
National Guardsman I mean we're seeing
daring high water rescues one after the
other after the other
and I'll say even more incredibly we're
just seeing neighbors rising up you know
when when this started the county does
and local officials put out a call
that's just to city residents if you
have a flat-bottomed boat can help
please do so yesterday I went to the
Harris County Emergency Operations
Center and they have an entire wall
covered with posters of people who
called in and and said I've got a boat
I've got a jetski I've got stuff you've
got something that we can help rescue
and their numbers and and and the Harris
County Center would basically operate it
as a dispatch if people called in and
distress that they had hundreds of
private citizens just saving the lives
of their neighbor so our focus right now
is on the preservation of life once once
this storm your seed then it will then
the focus will be on rebuilding
senator I know you were here at this
convention center yesterday you know it
grew to over 9,000 overnight they don't
even have enough cots for the people
that are here there was a call for help
yesterday from the city of Houston if
any medical professionals can come
volunteer please come volunteer are you
concerned that there wasn't enough
preparation
well yeah I'm certainly concerned that
the burden of the storm is exceeding all
of the projections and that no one
anticipated that the flooding would have
this magnitude and continue for this
long usually when you have a flood event
it occurs and you have rescues but then
you're very quickly moving to the
rebuilding because the waters receded
what is different is we're sitting here
now and it's still raining you know you
mentioned that the president is coming
Corpus Christi my I hope to come down to
Corpus and visit him but it but it's
very much up in the air if I could
physically get there mind the plan is to
get in a pickup truck in about a half
hour and try to drive but but the
freeways have been closed and so it may
be a very short trip if it proves that
we can't get out of Houston I hope that
we can but but if not I'll continue to
spend the day in Houston going back and
visiting with those displaced from their
homes and I will say this nor as you
talked to the people at the shelter the
overwhelming sentiment from everyone I
spoke to with just just relief that you
know they're sad that their homes or the
possessions are damaged but
overwhelmingly relieved their lives but
their lives are safe their families are
safe and there's a real appreciation
that at the end of the day that's that's
what matters most senator you're exactly
right there's a huge amount of gratitude
that those who have been rescued are
safe thank you so much for joining us
stay in touch with us thank you god
bless